you haven't been back for a while like
it's almost been two years like that's a
long time when you really think about it
yeah i guess we're like coming right up
on the two-year the two-year anniversary
here so
i am a little bit just nervous to see
the condition that it's been left in um
i don't know what's in the fridge that's
probably the scariest thing to me right
now but you know a lot has happened in
the past two years
um obviously a huge global pandemic but
also i got pregnant i had a baby i
breastfed that baby
um i had
i had my son in school for the first
time so
there were a lot of transitions and for
that reason i just felt like it was
safest and
most efficient for me to start filming
at home but i'm really excited to
be back and to take a look at where we
left off
[Music]
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor clue so if you follow me on tick
tock or instagram you might know that i
finally got my natural period back after
15 years on the pill and five grueling
years of ivf pregnancy and breastfeeding
i never thought i would be so excited
about cramps and bloating but it really
felt like my big accomplishment of the
year since then i've been using clue to
track my cycle so i know what's normal
for me when i'm ovulating or when i'm
entering other phases of my cycle and i
finally have real data to share with my
healthcare team it also helps me make
sense of some of the different symptoms
i'm experiencing each month whether
that's changes in my skin mood digestion
etc that way i know when there's
something abnormal going on or when it's
just good old and flow it has been
really eye opening for me to be able to
put these pieces together for my own
health so if you want to check out clue
for yourself you can download it on
iphone or android in the app store by
searching for period tracker today
do you remember this place it's been
here in so long i know what
gosh
totally of a time before the pandemic
truly easier easier days oh my gosh
simpler times i want to know what was
left
in the fridge like i'm terrified did you
leave stuff in there yeah probably
because i didn't probably know that i
wasn't gonna come back
i just like made the call yeah oh my
gosh i thought there was rice in here i
was terri i was gonna throw up nope just
an empty pot thank goodness did you
still have all your like spices yeah
the plants made it
are they real they are real oh my gosh
so this is why you get like packed up
cacti
because they can make it through a
pandemic with absolutely no love wow
they're coming back guys
oh my gosh this sunlight has completely
like lightened all my books
and
i need to see inside the fridge
a lot of beer that milk definitely has
to go
it stinks
i have
cheese
that i am not going to open up
um that's going in the garbage
this has been here for two years yogurt
oh my gosh
no
nope this also this all has to go
does flax like survive
oh
oh
oh what
well this is what happens to cilantro
when it sits in a crisper drawer for two
years oh whoa smells like some vomit
took a dump in here what happened
well we got a lot of butter
a lot of butter in the freezer
an excessive amount of bread that is
still good thank you freezer so we can
have a lot of sandwiches today oh my
goodness i made these on my
side
[Music]
is there like mold on it or is that just
like the frost
either way i don't think it's gonna be
fed to the children i don't think anyone
should know
no we will thaw this out and throw this
out
oh i'm like what is beeping this thing
does not enjoy
movements
on top of it
okay snacks
so there's just
but
we can make tea
and coffee
should i see how stale these are
i mean like consuming your own rest all
right
rockin ranch
it's rockin
hard as a rock
all right that's a no
[Music]
please remain seated
[Music]
so
if you recognize the kitchen behind me
you are probably an og
abby's kitchen subscriber so thank you
um but i think a lot of people
always assumed that this was like
my home but i actually built this
kitchen as like a studio space outside
of my home and that was really like my
first step in making youtube like my
full-time gig
so before this space i had a partner and
i was filming in her space but i really
had this dream of having my own studio
my own place that i could set up and
call my own and do my recipe testing and
do my filming and just have it all be
mine and have it my way so for about a
year and a half i would have my whole
team here on wednesdays and we would do
filming on wednesdays and recipe
development on fridays
and anyone that's been an entrepreneur
knows how lonely that life is so it was
just really nice to have that
camaraderie and teamwork going on but
then of course the pandemic hit no
no
like most people i would say um kovid
just
rocked my world both personally and also
professionally so while i was trying to
navigate a pregnancy and a pandemic and
also parent a toddler turned preschooler
i also was trying to figure out how to
run my business and grow my business all
on my own and a lot of mistakes for me
so at the beginning of the pandemic my
husband started to step in as like my dp
which disaster zone let's just say then
i was trying to do it on my own and film
all of my videos and shoot my food
content all on my own
and let's just say at some point in the
pregnancy i was just getting so big it
was very hard
risky for me to be shooting my own
content anymore like getting up onto a
table to get an overhead shot of like a
food plate not so great when you're like
eight months pregnant so like any
mompreneur i had to make choices and
that really meant delegating whatever i
could so that i could continue to grow
my business along my career trajectory
while still you know having a new baby
at home breastfeeding that baby taking
my kid to school and home at the end of
the day having that mom and me time
um but of course still staying the
course on what i want to accomplish for
abby's kitchen so i know when i started
youtube there was a ton of pressure to
like basically do it all as a youtuber
you know you had to edit your own videos
you had to script them yourselves you
had to film them yourselves maybe you
got your like boyfriend involved but the
expectation was that it was all on you
because you want to have that intimate
connection with your audience but as a
mom and for those of you who are parents
at home you probably can appreciate
that we need to make choices we cannot
do it all we cannot wear all of the hats
and not expect ourselves to drop balls
like all the time so that's when i made
the executive decision that i really had
to bring on some experts to just help me
navigate this youtube world so i could
focus on making the best content
possible for all of you hi i'm anthony
i'm uh abby's creative producer and
actually abby brought myself and my team
on to help navigate a lot of the
challenges that came with the pandemic
hitting her like process of filming and
creating youtube content i come from the
og youtube world much like abby and
there was a lot of pressure back then to
be these sort of like self-contained
businesses where you had to do
everything yourself you had to edit
everything yourself and it becomes
really hard and abby took on a lot of
responsibility not only growing a
channel during a time where there was a
lot of uncertainty in the world but
there was also a lot of responsibility
at home so i was excited to
you know join the team and brody who is
behind the camera is the expert meme
placer
boom knew it tell us about it please and
the man who makes all of abby's videos
happen and it's cool to see the channel
evolve because when i was here first
many years ago before abby and i were
actually working together it just seemed
like she was on the brink of something
great and when you get thrown a pandemic
at you it's like you have to pivot and
change and make decisions and it's scary
you don't know what's going to happen so
it's kind of nostalgic to be back here
and to see
uh how everything has progressed because
the last year has been crazy abby's
channel has grown so much so abby
obviously i have the insider scoop
because i know you
but can you tell us anything about
what's coming up next um
i would say
that i am launching
something huge that the wellness
industry is not ready for but let's get
them ready and trust me they're gonna be
ready because i'm filming every step of
the way ah
we
had so much fun and it was just like
such a whirlwind of a day that we
totally forgot to shoot a proper outro
to the video um but i wanted to thank
you guys so much for coming along with
me on little behind the scenes action a
big thank you to clue for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on any other kind of fun blogs
that you want to see me do subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]